como la hambre para su regreso a una
gran vuelta en este 2022 él sí cree
tener lan desde el jumbo misma correrá
el giro de italia después del respiro
que se tomó el año pasado por salud
mental y que lo tuvo siete meses fuera
de competición en el marco de esta
preparación de humo lana entrenada por
estos días en las carreteras de
antioquia en el noroccidente de colombia
el ganador del giro de italia en 2017 se
alejó de la bicicleta en el primer
semestre de 2021 por esas cuestiones de
salud mental decía que había perdido el
amor por la bicicleta y ahora dice que
ha vuelto a disfrutar del deporte que
ama además cambió la tradición a la
tradicional preparación en las hermosas
islas canarias para venirse a que
colombia en donde según él hay más
facilidades en lo que se refiere a la
logística de su entreno ya no tiene que
ir cambiando entre la altitud y el lugar
en donde se hospedan ahora todo se lo
puede decir aquí en colombia nuestro
compañero rodrigo sedano habló con él en
una rueda de prensa que ofreció su
equipo aquí en colombia y esto fue lo
que nos contó tom
james no sentía que necesitaba cambiar
mis metas o la manera en la que
entrenaba en realidad eso no cambió
tanto
yo sólo quiero disfrutar mientras monto
en la bicicleta y creo que eso es lo más
importante para
mí así que sobre eso hablé con mi
entrenador puedes hacer todo el
entrenamiento que quieras todo el
entrenamiento perfecto que quieras pero
si no lo disfrutas claro que no tiene
sentido
así que ahora tenemos la combinación
perfecta conmigo disfrutando de la
bicicleta y también haciendo el
entrenamiento correcto para llegar al
mejor punto en mis carreras